hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until dawn now in
the last episode people informed me that
I made very very very bad choices but
what else is new
I do but the way that people inform me
saying that things was going okay Matt
sided with Emily during a fight with
Jessica Emily was sympathetic to Matt
wait okay that's a little bit far behind
and which one will die
Ashley was grateful and felt in depth
indebted to Chris okay alrighty then
who gets the gun Emily kept the flare
gun Matt had no defense against the
attack okay that's one of the things
here that I have a big problem with
because this insinuates that I would
have somehow had a clue that Matt would
have been the one that was attacked
because there was no storytelling clue
to say that Emily would have been the
one that was helpless and not able to do
that how in that moment was I to know
that Matt would have been attacked how
in that moment would I have known
anything that was leading up to the fact
attack would have happened okay that's
just my grievance with it like I have no
problem in knowing that I'm dumb and
made wrong choice I have no problem with
that I do that all the time but I would
like some sort of clue to let me know
that I should do that and also someone
else told me that me trying to save
Emily was actually the wrong choice
maybe this was enlightenment Matt tried
to save Emily Matt fell into the mine
and was attacked how was I know that
saving or trying to save her was a bad
choice it seems like the game wants to
right Emily's character and I'm not
saying this is my opinion of her but it
seems like the game wants to right Emily
as the [ __ ] who doesn't deserve to live
that's my opinion of what this game sees
from Emily I'm very passionate about
this in that it doesn't seem like there
was a lot of clues telling me that's
what it should have been doing but
anyway so that's all I'll have to say
about that
I will say I did wrong so Ashley took
the scissors that's good I'm with Ashley
and Chris who so far I have made the
right choices as far as I know
so anyway is it love could be love
mm-hmm yeah down to that okay it feels
like he's constructing this whole story
for us and watching us run around
freaking out somewhat we do like it's
like it's some sort of [ __ ]
experiment yeah okay I agree that's kind
of yeah that actually makes a weird sort
of sense yeah right so let's get down
and party like porn stars man maybe
maybe we should just break loose man
Chris you just gotta got a go for it man
get into her pants man it's Josh
I know it's Josh I have so many feelings
that this is Josh's fault Josh's behind
this Josh somehow faked his own death
Josh is behind this
oh that looks not good I probably
shouldn't touch that uh-huh okay
batteries and timers so what does this
clue mean maybe I should maybe maybe I
should read more into what these mean
because batteries and switches timers
wired together looks like they're used
to control electronic devices remotely
okay so maybe this is how they projected
the ghostly lady to jump into my face
would make a lot of sense I don't even
know if we're supposed to be down here I
mean at least we're together but hey man
Emily were together and you saw how that
ended up oh god no I don't like
mannequins whatever the game really did
to do somehow that I have autonomy
phobia which means fear of inanimate
objects and when they move it's not cool
started all the way way back in
nightmare house ooh I didn't even know I
had a fear of mannequins until nightmare
I was to like three years
[ __ ] great okay I'm just gonna make a
grimace cuz I'm scared I mean this is
all well and good I mean I love the
decoration in this place is awfully
fancy I God what do we have here
catalogue of all the horrible choices I
made oh no oh no no okay this Chris is
Mike up there the Sam that's one of the
twins and that looks like Josh who's got
eyes cut out well I have a sneaking
suspicion it could be you never know you
never know yeah it's amazing how much
these horror games reveal a lot about my
own personality in addition to
everything all that's going on here okay
where did he you run off to wait wait
wait whoa let's not be so hasty there
Chrissy poo let's see what might be
going on over here anything
Oh oh my am I supposed to be in here
Oh Chrissy baby seems to be a projector
of some sort here oh good idea who was
filming it she's so excited and alive
no idea oh geez
see unrepentant no apology I couldn't
feel worth yeah couldn't feel worse
that's how I feel about this bull I mean
she does seem like a nice character it
was supposed to be funny
oh yeah I forgot that that Chris wasn't
actually a part of it think about it
hook up video cameras I don't know maybe
the same person who tied you up
you killed Josh yeah sense might have
Sam right now
yeah I still don't understand why man
Emily split up after all of that
happened I don't know why Matt and Emily
split up and went somewhere else they
should have all stayed together okay so
I want to see what this new thing was
wait art already knew this I knew this
Matt was killed okay yeah I know that I
saw it firsthand it was bad I'm a dumb I
get it I made a terrible choice even
even if there were clues I didn't see
them you know it's like it's my fault I
readily admit that's bad I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to keep these two
alive god I want them to live I want
them to become a happy couple get
married have lots of babies and just go
on and forget that she's covered in
blood
what I'm gonna follow that ain't no way
I'm gonna split this both ways putting
me up it's a bunch of bull okay I don't
know yours heads because you're still
here
alright there's someone in here puppies
okay yeah yeah probably you were about
to go find him and I gave you this I
want to these two to survive I'm trying
to do whatever it takes to keep them
alive
[Music]
is it a recording don't go running off
into the darkness just yet be sure to
like carefully and calmly carefully and
calmly I'm sure that the game will wait
for us we just need to go carefully and
calmly carefully and calmly alright
maybe there's something over here hang
on let us let us investigate thoroughly
before we go anywhere else
ooh another dory now what's back over
here
oh nothing solid wall just slam my face
into a solid wall everyone ignore that
okay
I'm gonna try to see what's in this door
first oh my goodness it's locked
maybe that's the exit door when we start
running out of here at full speed that's
what we need to do anyway alright follow
along Chrissy poo light of my life one
who's gonna get me out here alive
[Music]
and party like a porn star man oh great
oh no oh no oh no oh no I don't want to
do this I don't want to do this again
god damn it
it's gonna make me do this again yeah
good good move there bro no one's gonna
find anything say about it
tell me why we're always talking around
it and now everything that I spent with
you was the only thing I ever wanted to
do with my time
[Music]
I've seen a prediction of this I've seen
maybe that's what maybe that's my clue
maybe that was my clue that I was
supposed to get maybe that was my clue
because frankly it must have been Oh
these this toes must be the only thing
that I get okay guidance okay yeah okay
guidance I put it on the table put it on
the table found near the fire tower by
Emily so if I look him I didn't actually
get to all of these I should have gotten
to all these oh man I should have been
paying more attention
oh sure I should have been finding these
little better okay yep I mean I don't
know what else could have been done
about that uh-huh okay right right okay
so that that must have been mad that
might have been mad I don't know that
was idiot those idiot they're okay now
we knew about okay so there's probably a
lot of totems that I've missed so with
that being said Oh
sometimes after the prospectors came to
mind this mountain until a caving
Margaret I year ago why have I never
seen that before why have I never ever
seen that before
what the hell is going on okay this is
making a little more sense now okay I
take back everything I was rambling
about but the very important thing is
this guidance totem right here showing
me that I need to put this gun back on
the table somehow it's not showing like
I don't put it to my head I don't put it
to anyone's head I put it back on the
table
wait stop me
[Music]
let me choose to save you
if I do one last thing in my life let me
do this
okay wait wait wait I'm gonna do nothing
I'm gonna do nothing I'm gonna do
nothing I'm gonna do nothing I'm gonna
do absolutely nothing I'm gonna do
nothing guidance guidance
[Music]
what happened well you're gonna cut it
out like that what the hell's going on
here for now have I gone too far towards
your porn that's gone too far I agree I
agree very much see the right to play
God these people's lives yeah make you
special then huh ha he's got an injured
shoulder it's so fascinating is this all
in his head you're a sick [ __ ] what the
hell have you done to them psychopath
five bad did I make the right choice I
think I might have made the right choice
there I think I might have made the
right choice okay that oh okay
it always sucks because I'm always like
halfway or more than halfway through the
game before I realize fully what the
game wants from me because when we do
these Let's Plays I always like start
off like all right totally open the
choice but then like I don't piece it
all together until like I'm already
through it but a game like this the
choices matter but I get it now
I get it but I'm afraid that I already
don't know enough because I haven't
picked enough up other totems I should
have been looking out lot better than I
had oh I should have been looking at way
more corners and baubles
I bet there was a I bet there was a
totem saying like the give the gun gives
a flare gun to man or you know oh man
that would have been so much better but
it is what it is I learned from my
mistakes I'll probably play this again
on my own for hours until dawn not soon
enough
how'd you get here how did you get here
you blew up scooty do scooty scoot e wu
d wu scooter booty scooty bootchie
bootchie bootch scoochie Buchi come on
little more beauty boots come on baby
scoot steel boots scoot a little mooch
all right there you shoot it off shoot
it with your bow Hey oh yeah oh
scooti Buchi I got this I'm doing things
right maybe maybe
uh-huh
there's a joke in there somewhere but
I'm not gonna make it at this point
let's see uh wait hang on curious how'd
you get down here shock your fingers
that's not important right now curious
about how you got down here that's more
important like web of tunnels I was down
there trying to get out and then I found
this great I saw you
listen this guy who you're talking about
he attacked me I know you won't open can
you unlock it from your side I will try
you'd be awfully strange if I was in
prison where I could just open up
whatever I have but I'm gonna look for a
totem first goddamn totems goddamn
important freakin totems
where's the goddamn totems oh that's
ain't good know told I was over here
what you're not gonna give me any
guidance I need four frigging guidance
I'm a freaking dog I'm a naked baby
wandering around in the snow you're not
gonna give me any guidance I really do
wonder I'm gonna actually I should have
been looking at these clues the second I
get them psycho is collecting footage of
what's going on of course he is and some
of them are hooked up wirelessly for
some bizarre reason oh look at the way
the lights plays oh that's so pretty
I will admit this game is very pretty
but there are times when like the
framerate dips quite a bit hello flasher
light thanks booger bag you would have
thought that towel would have fell off a
long time ago in the hustle and bustle
of things it's like superglue to her
body yep
not bad at all okay so is there a totem
over here huh totem oldham told me
welcome oh look at burro Tilden anybody
seen a toad I'm told I'm told I'm told
him okay so I can't open this bear not
be booby-trapped
I better not lose anything else
especially my boobles
come on there we go
we made it yeah sure does
yeah I don't give him a hugger anything
he probably got cooties or some weird
things what are you doing well actually
the tower didn't turn out to be the best
out there fighting off logic logic Oh
oh yeah right yeah turn your back on
your friend oh do I have to interact
with this too
do I have to press r2 to get my clothes
on and off well that was quick I guess
there's nothing to see here all right
Hey
No Oh
[Music]
Chris Oh Chris Chris Chris Chris [ __ ]
you've heard of blanks before I mean
really
I called it someone pick up the food his
I freaking called it
Oh it's Emily oh oh I thought Emily was
dead I could have sworn Emily was dead I
take back everything I said at the
beginning of this episode because it was
before I knew I was stupid I admitted I
was wrong in every way I take that full
credit I'm very stupid okay let's not
blow ourselves up somehow cuz that's
entirely possible
yep come on you swing a ling a ling
swinging a ling a ling swing a ling Ling
don't impale yourself please dear God
don't fail yourself wow that could have
ended in horrible horrible death what
I'm glad it didn't because I'm an expert
at whatever I'm doing now
alright oh damn it I guess
oh I was fine it was a two foot drop and
I should have gotten more totems if I
had only known god I was such an idiot
an episode before this I was such an
idiot such a fool
why did I let that happen
was it's not important enough to do
mm-hmm
I don't like this is making me a
crumpled guess I'm a crumpled Marquis
puh I'm a crumpled little wobble thin
okay yeah you frankly ripped your leg
open oh that's what you worried about
yeah priorities here I guess she doesn't
know she hasn't had a garden stone him
to tell her what happened to her
boyfriend it's so sad though man I was
too stupid I'm such an idiot god I'm so
stupid I mean I'm not stupid I'm just I
wasn't uh I wasn't putting the pieces
together quickly enough I'm still busy
making KitKat jokes what a doof I am now
I see the anger of what everyone is
doing I'm angry at myself damn it
no no she's gonna walk in the mat oh
it's gonna be so sad oh come on oh oh
maybe she's not in the same exact area
that she was there a totem or anything
I've been looking around oh okay maybe
your men I'm surprised how much all of
this is actually connected because it
seems all very intertwined with what's
going on here look I thought when Mike
and Mike and Jess were going up into the
mountains that there was like it was way
far away far removed from everything
that was going on but I didn't realize
everything was actually closed I guess
they went up the tower is up in the
mountains technically I'm keeping an eye
out I don't see any totems unless I just
missed it right by then cuz I do have to
look into the camera which means I take
my eye off completely from what's going
on the game oh crap I done goofed
I done goofed we all done done maybe
maybe I did something wrong in that when
I was in the in the maybe in the vision
I actually read that wrong and I was
supposed to go from myself and try to
shoot myself I thought from what it said
when it looked like it looked very
specifically like it meant totem totem
totem totem to them for them
what are we having here come on Oh clue
I'll take a clue
no douche the blasting crew preparing to
dynamite the new shafts Northwest mines
December 1951
okay new clue about that crap okay so
that's all part of another thing instead
of a photo of a group of miners called
the blasting crew on reverse okay
they were blasting new tones great
that's all the information I actually
need to go to that one I'm so glad I
read that by knew I knew that Josh was
the psycho I called that one Lisa I was
able to piece that together before
everything went to [ __ ] now that we do
have the problem that there's an actual
monster somewhere in here like an actual
legitimate monster on these hills that's
something to do with Native American
culture some people have said it's a
Wendigo and what a Wendigo is I actually
know don't fully understand but I would
think they would have better tell them
around here somewhere well I guess not I
guess I shall move on soonish and do
good for some reason I remember that
from half-life 2 was it episode 1 I
think might have been something like
that hey the way she looks so blase
about whatever is happening here I can't
believe my life gets any worse hey
that's handy dandy oh well some of the
smells bad here sorry I got I don't like
this I like this something smells very
bad about here some smells very bad so
either way I guess she's not I thought
for sure like the totems can lead me
astray - if I don't realize what they're
going because I thought that when Emily
was falling I I guess I could have
assumed that I thought that those the
totems here's my misunderstanding with
the domes I thought the totems were like
possible outcomes not literal things
that happen or like I didn't realize
that they were the ideal path you were
supposed to take I think if that's my
understanding so I don't really know but
in the case of the death ones I was
zooming of something you were trying to
avoid therefore I was trying to save her
from a fiery death I don't know it is
what it is I'll pick this up in another
episode
this episode has been quite the learning
experience for me so I hope you guys are
forgiving of my stupidity I'm probably
still wrong about a lot of things so
thank you all so much for watching I'll
get to the next episode very soon and as
always I will see you
[Music]